natürlich ist die frage hätte man noch
mehr tun können da man hat immer wieder
gehört wie die frau nach hilfe gerufen
hat und genau darüber haben wir
gesprochen mit jens schobranski erst
sprecher der bundespolizei und hat uns
erklärt wie man in diesen fällen helfen
kann ohne sich selbst in gefahr zu
bringen
man muss helfen man muss sie ein bischen
einfach nur 30 dem weg zu gucken und zu
sagen in andere reagiert schon das ist
hier das falsche signal
hier geht es darum dass man sicherlich
gucken was jede situation für sich
selbst ein einzelfall man muss den die
reagiert hat die da ist ja sehr
aggressiv in dem fall ja auch draußen
mit rot auch die anderen umständen hier
ist immer gut nicht alleine trainieren
immer eine mehrheit zu bilden andere
reisende anzusprechen gezielt
aufgefordert mit einzuwirken dass ob sie
zu schützen und aufgaben zu verteilen
nein zu sagen bitte ruft die polizei
informiere andere order to fix dass mit
dem innerhalb beweiswert haben und
mehrere andere möglicherweise auch
männer land zu stellen da kommen wir gut
auf den täter zu und training fahren man
muss auch das opfer anstellung sagen
komm zu uns wir schützen dich also da
ist doch gezählt derzeit dass sich die
situation nicht richtig und man sich
einfach nicht fragt so kann also jeder
im alltag helfen wenn er zeuge wird von
einem angriff auf einen anderen menschen